so the first panel of our Brazilian
styles in the United States the road
ahead conference is the panel of
anthropology ecology and environmental
science and he will start now and it
lasts for a total of 90 minutes what
we're going to do is start introducing
what the panel is all about then
introduce to you our three panelists
that we have here and then the panelists
will be presenting for 15 minutes and
their views on our major question which
I will tell you in a minute and after
each presentation each presentation will
be 15 minutes and I will open after each
presentation five minutes for questions
about that presentation and then the
next presentation goes on and then at
the end of the three presentations we'll
have some time for general discussion
from the audience from ourselves first I
will ask everyone to give their final
remarks or some closing remarks and then
I'll open it for everyone so how do you
like that yeah all right so the task
that we have in in our panel on
anthropology ecology and environmental
science is answering the following
question and the question is look at
this thinking about the development and
protection of large biomes how do
studies about Brazil and exchange of
knowledge with Brazilian universities
contribute to this debate in u.s.
academies cite examples from personal
research experience so that's our task
and it's a real big one when you think
about large biomes what comes to mind
we're thinking about Brazil well
obviously we're thinking about the
Amazon and the Atlantic forest I can
never say the Amazon alone I always have
to say Atlantic forest because much of
my
research and education life happened
there both biomes and we all know the
importance of both force in terms of
biodiversity the legacy that those
forests have it's absolutely incredible
some of the largest biodiversity of the
world's house there and in Brazil
because as you know the Amazon is not
only Brazil but we have a quadrant
Colombia and Peru and Bolivia etcetera
but by far Brazil houses the largest
portion of the Amazon and as you very
well know many parts of the Amazon are
legally protected parts of large parts
of the Amazon are legally protected so
that's our first challenge when we're
trying to answer this question those
parts that are legally protected are
they really protected or are they on
paper so what do we need for that we
need the governance the social
environment the cultural setting the
economic factors operate in there okay
so that's one part and the other part is
there are a very large areas of a what
used to be the Amazon sadly enough that
have been converted and that conversion
was very intense in the 1960s but then
he continued and then it slowed down and
then it continued again and it slowed
down it goes up and down and now the
reality is what we have we have large
areas of what used to be Amazon that
they have been converted into something
that looks like a savanna in parts
grasslands in our parts and they are
developed into cattle ranches soybean
farming and many other things and
they're also urban centers and on there
so it's a very complex biome to and then
what's the challenge there well maybe
the challenge could be that even those
very fragmented types of logs landscapes
house some biodiversity if we help and
contribute to creating biodiversity
Islands within those biomes and those
biodiversity islands which would be
pockets of protected force or planted
for
restore force may help restoring some of
the former biodiversity or preserve
endure by the biodiversity that is there
and helping in connectivity of those
fragmented landscapes so that's from the
physical point of view again the
challenges are huge because we're
talking about rural environments urban
environments as well and just because
this is my chance to say something
because the our panelists have the
privilege of having a total of 15
minutes each I don't but they have to
say that Brazil has a unique opportunity
in 2018 it's the youthful World Congress
happening in Curitiba in Brazil so
that's a great opportunity for us to
continue from here from our school I'm
sure from the forestry and environmental
studies school school of forestry and
environmental studies there are many
people who will be going and it's
happening in its Kalima imagine the the
title of the conference it's the World
Congress 2019
it's from the 29th of September to the
5th of October and this the title is
interconnecting forests science and
people that's what they try to do and
they dedicate to forest research and
cooperation for sustainable development
so I encourage you to check it out is
very very simple you Flores
international union of forest research
organizations for those of you who are
not in the forestry field and the
website is you flow iufro dot org so
check it out and maybe we'll all see
each other in unity a real nice location
of Atlantic rainforest alright so I
started right off and I didn't say Who I
am because I always think everyone knows
me but maybe that's not the case so my
name is Florence I'm Antonini I'm
originally from Argentina
I came to yell in 1989 as a professor of
tropical ecology and then I had
different titles am now a senior
research scientist
at the school of forest and
environmental studies and my work has
happened all over Latin America
including my home country for its
antenna in the subtropical region of
Misiones which is part of what's called
the interior Atlantic rainfalls
and in Brazil I have worked a lot and
I'm still working in Brazil in regions
of Atlantic forest doing restoration
with native tree species my work has
always been restoration and agroforestry
alright so now I'm going to introduce
our three panelists it will be such a
pleasure to throw this to the other
peoples starting on my right is Suzanne
Oakdale she's an associate professor of
anthropology at nology at the University
of New Mexico
she started there in 1998 she offers
several undergraduate and graduate level
courses for Latin American Studies
students topics such as ritual
activities contemporary significance
theory in ethnology identity
construction in contemporary
multicultural Brazil Tyler and lowland
peoples of South America other other
peoples as well she specializes in
Brazil with research focus on Amazonian
indigenous peoples ok-jung only she's an
assistant professor of Earth
environmental and Planetary Sciences in
Brown University she studied earth
science education and chemistry at sail
National University in South Korea she
also received her master's from Seoul
National University and her graduate
studies we're at the University of
California at Berkeley focusing on the
interpretation of Antarctic temperatures
during the glacial time using stable
isotope signatures and climate modeling
she also worked at the University of
Chicago and NASA long trajectory even
though she's so young
and bad doctor badly sir she's a
professor of wildlife ecology and
conservation and she directs the center
for tropical conservation and
development program which is part of the
Center for Latin American Studies at the
University of Florida she's been there
in Florida since 2011 she has been at
the National Science Foundation she has
held other positions her research
focuses on understand and importance of
biodiversity in tropical systems the
ecological role of animals as seed
dispersers the potential consequences of
global change on distribution of plants
and animals evolutionary ecology of Lac
mating systems in birds and much of her
research being conducted in Ecuador Ian
Amazon but the other sites for her
research has have been or are still
there 24th of Brazil the Andes of
Colombia and tropical wet forests of
Australia all right so you can see that
we have a very diverse panel but that's
exactly what we need if we want to
answer our question because as I said at
the beginning there are all these kinds
of social interactions cultural
interactions economic factors that have
something to do with land use changes
and transformations in the landscape so
we need a panel such as what we have so
I'm going to ask Beth Lisa to present
first and then we'll go there to watch
and then we'll continue thank you very
much Laura Florencia for that very nice
introduction
I can no longer see the desktop on here
to locate my powerpoint did it go to
sleep maybe or maybe it's not I should
be hitting main display thank you it is
really a privilege and an honor to be
here and to be with such just
distinguished folks that are here from
Brazil and from Yale universities and
and colleagues from elsewhere I'm gonna
take an approach today that is really
more from an institutional approach to
this question I'd love to show you my
dance videos of mannequins in tropical
rainforest but I'm gonna talk more to
the subject that we have today and and
I'm gonna start out with the sort of the
audience participation of my talk which
is to ask how many of you know dr.
Carlos no brain or no of him a number of
you do he's he's an international expert
on climate he's a very renowned
scientist from Brazil he was former
secretary of research and development at
the ministry of science technology and
innovation of brazil he's former
president of the agency for postgraduate
education or copies in brazil he was a
member of the IPCC he is a foreign
member of the US National Academy of
Sciences a member of the Brazilian
Academy of Sciences a member of the
world Academy of Sciences he as you as
you can tell he's a very distinguished
individual and I'd like to mention us as
I already been mentioned here is I mean
the ability of the University of Florida
to attract such incredible Brazilian
scientists world scientists to the
University just doesn't happen overnight
it happens because of a long history of
connections and so you know we do have
the pleasure of working in beginning
collaborations with dr. know Bray but
when you look back I mean our
interactions with Brazil I'm sure go be
well beyond or before this time but
recently in the Gainesville Sun which is
our local newspaper was this article
that was published reminding us that a
former dean of the College of
Agriculture and life sciences was
invited by the then governor of the
state of meanness did ice to help them
establish a university which is now
currently called the viscose ephedra
University and he brought that sort of
land-grant institution type philosophy
of research extension and teaching to
Brazil back in in the 1920s and directed
that for for some time so why the
University of Florida and Brazil there
be a you know there's a number of
different reasons why we have such
connections to Brazil one is our history
and legacy of partnership with Brazil
institutions the the teaching of the
Portuguese language was mentioned today
about when it started at Yale University
it was first taught at the University of
Florida in 1949 or 1914 excuse me
and it's been taught regularly since
1939 we have the oldest Center for Latin
American Studies and its was founded in
1930 and is a very active and engaging
center we have a lot of our faculty and
researchers that work in Brazil a number
of them are brazilians and we get a lot
of research dollars from US agencies
that conduct our research in Brazil and
we have lots and lots of graduate
students from Brazil over the years a
lot in agriculture but a lot and a lot
of other different disciplines as well
and and we like to say we think we've
hosted more science Without Borders
students than any other institution in
the US and so we have distinguished
alumni as well for the program I'm
involved in on the topic that morph its
today director of the tropical
conservation development program we can
trace our roots back really to win
charles waggly a very well-known
anthropologist left Columbia University
Long distinguished career there to join
us at the University of Florida and so
our legacy began with Charles waggly
and together with Maryann Schmidt on
anthropologist and Chuck wood a
sociologist they started the Amazon
research and training program and many
of the components of this program that
began in the 1980s are still components
that are so integral to us today
including very importantly you know
getting people to the field providing
money for people to get to the field but
having these collaborations with
Brazilian scientists and others from
government and from NGOs and so forth
collaborating with them and starting
long-term lasting collaborations which
are so important in order to build a
sense of trust and a level of comfort
that allows you to share ideas and
different worldviews with each other so
one of them showing you one of the
newsletters that came out in 1989 I want
to draw your attention to just a couple
of things one it's talking about one of
the relationships we have with the
University of Accra which is a
collaborative program that began
sometime in the 80s and is still ongoing
and very strong today addressing a lot
of different questions of relevance to
this topic and the other is really this
is when the tropical conservation
development program began with a grant
from the Ford Foundation and as it says
there's the grant is designed to sort of
strengthen interdisciplinary research
training and curriculum development to
address the related problems of
biological conservation and the
livelihoods of rural poor in Latin
America and for those of you that you
know are not as old as some of us here
the end is really important and as my
colleague Emilio Bruna says it's kind of
it's almost like a you know a
revolutionary ampersand because back in
the early 1980s and and I'm an ecologist
I certainly remember
the sort of the dogma of the day is
you're going to build these national
parks you're going to throw the people
out and that's what's going to conserve
biodiversity
so the real recognition that you have to
combine you have to view these as
related problems is really what drove a
lot of the early a RTP program as well
as the tropical conservation and
development program and this is sort of
our our framework and just very briefly
the TCD program does not give degrees
but what we are we give a graduate
certificate what we really are is or
community and we're community of faculty
and students and alums and partners that
all sort of have the shared vision of
working interdisciplinary on topics of
relevance in the areas in which we work
and so relevant to us here is this this
learning and Action Network what this
learning in Action Network really is is
our partners academic NGO etc our
partners that we work with in the field
are really critical to what we believe
to both our research and training
components at the University of Florida
because without those partners without
these long-term relationships we you
know we can't really practice the kind
of research that we want in the field
and have the kind of impact that we want
the other thing that's really important
here is the skills a lot of our students
whether they're from the US or whether
they're from Brazil or elsewhere come
with a lot of really great professional
experiences they come from Peace Corps
they come from NGOs or they come from
government and they bring a lot of these
skills with them and a lot of
experiences that we share but what we
recognize is to work collaboratively to
work on applied projects to work in a
transdisciplinary fashion or work at the
participatory research these take skills
that you don't learn in your home
department you know to work in teams to
deal with conflict to facilitate
these kinds of things are a real key
component of our projects and then
frankly I don't need to tell anybody
here this but you know working
collaboratively with local scientists of
course is the right thing to do and as
for many of the reasons that are
pictured on the slide and of course we
all probably recognize the infamous man
who took 70 thousand rubber seeds out of
Brazil in 1876 but working
collaboratively is also very
professionally and personally rewarding
and my colleague Emilio Bruna together
with Stefano elicina
from the University of Chicago Dobin to
about a million articles and kind of
analyzed these articles and to give you
the punchline of that they found that in
international collaboration if you
publish internationally and
collaboratively you have more citations
relative to other authors in the same
journal in the same year and you're
publishing in journals that have higher
impact factors now believe me that's
going to help you get tenure you know so
it's kind of important and when I look
at my field in ecology what this slide
is showing is if we use us as the base
these are the number of citations if
you're from these countries are from
collaborations among these countries
this is where the u.s. is Brazil is
actually a little bit higher but if you
publish with your Brazilian colleagues
look your impact factor goes way up
so again demonstrating that these are
good for science and they're good for
getting your research note notice by the
academic community well it you're really
working collaboratively is hard we all
recognize that and so you really do need
to I think to develop strategies and
mechanisms for being successful in
collaborative research and this sort of
shows some of the things that I think
that underline a lot of the
collaborations that we have you know the
formal agreements the two-way exchanges
north and south then and south and north
but as well south and south the kinds of
joint training courses that you can
together and we think about it at a
variety of different levels for example
at the technician level of people that
are on the ground the practitioners in
the field
maybe the groups that you're working
with or at the university level I
already mentioned like conflict
management or environmental governance
these are just some of the examples but
these kinds of things these training
courses these exchanges and so forth are
what are going to help you really
develop these truly collaboratively
applied research projects you have to
talk to each other you have to spend
time in the field together you have to
get comfortable with each other and find
out where you have shared interest and
and what the needs are and of course the
joint publications always help but
publications not only to the scholarly
community but we also help hope to local
stakeholders as well so I want to
continue and just give you a highlight
of a couple of the samples from the
University of Florida so we have
examples at the faculty level this is my
colleague Karen Kiner there's a picture
here of 1988 chico mendes is in this
picture and at that time karen Kiner was
a graduate student in forestry and just
beginning her dissertation research she
ended up doing a research in the
extractive reserve area in och ray and
for the next 30 years she has continued
research in anak ray with colleagues her
long-term colleague Lucia Vata and Bravo
with other colleagues rodrigo serrano at
the university with former students of
hers and students of these folks as well
so this is kind of the long-term
relationships that can be built and that
you can easily then bring your students
into and have them meet other students
from other institutions in Brazil and
this really scary slide is sort of some
of the evolution that we have had as a
program more program related projects
that combine a number of the faculty at
UF their students and our colleagues in
demian and ngos and i just want to
highlight a couple of them the we got a
big NSF grant a training grant from that
we called working forests in the tropics
and in 2000 I forget what it was 2001 or
something like that well of course if
you know these training grants from NSF
only fund people from the US so we were
able to get a major grant from the Moore
Foundation right then that that
established our Amazon Conservation
Leadership Initiative and that paid for
us to fund a lot of PhDs and masters
students from Amazon countries and
overall we had 18 PhD students six
master's students lots of visiting
professors back and forth between the
two over those years with the idea of
you're really strengthening our
relationships but also strengthening in
particular Amazonian universities it
involved a lot of the field courses
which I've talked about before but what
it also evolved that our three active
programs ongoing now are the Amazon dams
Network a kind of a family agriculture
project and the the Recon Network and
I'm going to briefly talk about the
Amazon dams Network this is an NSF
funded grant with a number of different
Brazilian universities were interested
in studying the socio-ecological River
systems in a truly intricate manner to
support planning and adaptive management
of areas transformed by hydroelectric
dams you see our partners there are many
different partners from Brazil many
different institutions we have four
countries involved 20 institutions but
the real leads have been the University
of Florida the Univ the federal
university of Tocantins and federal
university of Rondonia and it all began
not with the NSF grant in 2015 or 16 it
began a long time ago with the field
course and a really transformational
moment came when Ellen AG Marquez from
the federal University of Tocantins came
to Florida and we had people from all
over other Brazilians and so forth and
she said there you know says one of the
first times we met Ellen AG what unites
us is water and that was really
important
and it really began then to form the
kind of relationship that then built
with exchanges over the years that
finally led to the NSF project a you
know a meeting in the Glen Canyon Dam
and then more recently at the La Jolla
Dam in in Palmas and Tocantins and these
are some of the products that have come
out from us from the academic standpoint
but there's lots of other products as
well that are as I mentioned are going
to various different levels of
stakeholders and then finally my last
example is something that's just getting
started and it's going to be the what
we're gonna call the pan amazon
community of practice and it's going to
deal with this this tough issue of
infrastructure development and protected
area mosaics and Florencia mentioned you
know in her open comments about you know
these trends and deforestation and so
forth but what we have learned it's
really hard to scale up successful
projects it's really you know things can
happen then all of a sudden some
external force comes in and you know
you're back at square one are going
behind so the whole idea here is to
build this community of practice to look
at the tools and strategies we're
employing across the Amazon and to
figure out ways that we can learn from
each other to innovate those tools to
learn from the successes as well as from
the failures we're taking a focus and
three main area mosaics in the Amazon
including the Madera basin and in
southeast
excuse me Southwest Brazil and again
we're gonna have a lot of different
things going on there will be a lot of
activities looking at what factors
enable and limit effective governance
and so on and so forth in a hope that we
can develop the strategies that are
needed so this is supported by the Moore
Foundation so the kind of my last slide
is I answered this question by saying
this
a relationship with our colleagues and
Brazil both the academic institutions
and government agencies and
practitioners NGOs and so forth have
literally transformed the way we do
things at the University of Florida and
with that I think I'll stop thank you
just stay there for a few questions yes
yes we can have about five minutes of
questions for Abed yes Phillip front
side is a key member of our Amazon dance
network we've worked with Phil and that
phil was in the very early conversations
back in 2009 as we developed the program
and I know some others also had amazing
work what you do at TDC and I have been
familiar with the program for many many
years and it's very interdisciplinary
that's the least I can say but I mean
you gave much more detail I think it's
very interesting how you access funding
through your interdisciplinary team any
other comments or questions for bit yes
well that's a very complicated answer
but but I think that one of the the
issues with the big dams is the lack of
planning in terms of the local context
and getting people ready and perhaps
some of the environmental impact
statements or work evaluation that has
been done has not been as comprehensive
as it should have been and perhaps some
of the decisions to go ahead and license
some of these dams and operate
these dams those decisions would not
have happened under perhaps a fuller
evaluation of this yeah I'm trying to be
diplomatic there are simpler ways to
answer that question yes let's get the
last question done and every wrong yes
and yes I'll just say I should have said
that but I saw my two minutes coming up
the the Amazon dams Network includes not
only academics across all disciplines
lots of social scientists
anthropologists economists hydro
morphologist geomorphologist engineers
public prosecutors federal prosecutors
from Brazil the energy sector people
from the licensing agencies as well as
the planning agencies in in Brazil we
have indigenous peoples that come to our
meetings we we brought indigenous people
up to see the Glen Canyon Dam and they
interacted with Navajos and zuny's and
had conversations about you know shared
experiences and so forth so it's a very
diverse set of stakeholders which which
I will mention has led to you know we
have sometimes very conflict within our
meetings when we do get together and
discuss the the issues so it's a very
diverse group and I think that's we
really appreciate that there's a lot of
perspectives that come out of this group
all right well thank you very much
remember that at the end of our panel
sessions we'll have a general discussion
so you can keep back questions for later
so now I have the pleasure of
introducing Jim I'm sorry about
mispronouncing your name but I'm used to
people mispronouncing man what an
evening is the right way nobody says
that so we're all its close close enough
okay at least you know I'm talking to
you
[Music]
thank you for inviting me to this
exciting venue it's a great honor so I
study how the climate particularly how
plants you know interact with each other
and I also study how over geological
time scale ecosystem and the climate
system called evolve so how plants
influence the climate system so we we
have trees trees slow down the wind and
if you take a look at this video you see
that you know forest is darker than the
bare ground so it influences the amount
of energy that Earth absorbs and also
plant transpire trans transpiration
means that you know evaporation of over
leaves on leaves so plants take up order
and when they for a center site they
open stoma and co2 diffuses in and you
know plants assimilate carbon while
they're doing that because you know this
pore is open water diffuses out that's
called transpiration and just like us
sweating by doing that in a temperature
near the surface decreases so 20 only
influence that energy and water cycle of
the earth and today I'm going to talk
about how plants influence the influence
precipitation and also cloud types over
Amazonia
go to the next slide
this is I have a PDF reader
okay thank you
so this is a hypothetical case that you
know if we have plans but suppose that
you don't actually for the synthesizer
or a transponder so you know you can't
think of like you know trees are there
but they're like you know plastic trees
though they don't really work I'm gonna
climb in my work so I can do you know
[Music]
you know we cannot do for the real world
so in for this case I pretended that you
know the earth is covered by plants but
they don't for a synthesized or
transpire so and how that's going to
influence precipitation intensity so
what this figure shows is that you know
this part is no precipitation to very
light precipitation and this is you know
heavy precipitation so and you can think
of it as in a number of days per year so
for example if we remove transpiration
we are gonna have probably 10 more days
of no precipitation and we are gonna
have a bit more intense precipitation
the reason why the difference is high
here and load here is that you know we
have relatively less number of days with
very intense precipitation so by having
plants so in this case is removing
plants right so we if we remove plants
you know we are gonna have many more dry
days and many more very very you know
with many more days with extreme
presentation that's because you know if
we don't have plants
I mentioned that you know when plans for
a synthesised it they decrease the
surface temperature so if we remove
plants you know temperature is gonna go
up and on if temperature is higher or we
need more moisture to be able to
initiate precipitation so as a result
extreme precipitation both low and high
ends
increase so this is for the UH the case
with the Amazon so here I'm going from
30 West this is over a 20 Cohen and this
is you know and these so I'm looking at
the longitude here you know and this is
so from here to there so if I don't have
any plans what the the time that matters
most is October
that's the onset of the West season and
what you see is that most of
precipitation occurs near the Andes so
mean wind here is easterly meaning that
wind is wind is blowing from the east
from the ocean and then it hits the end
ease and major precipitation occurs here
but because we have but because we have
amazon basin with large
evapotranspiration now we have more
precipitation here in brazil in over
Amazonia so so precision in Amazonia and
particularly the frequency of
precipitation and the length of the
rainy season depends on the existence of
the the forest so I looked at the timing
of the wet season so as I mentioned you
know if we have plants where season
comes much earlier if we don't have
plants where season would come much
later so this is a this is the this is
actually a case with you know hype
transpiration and low transpiration so
historically in terms of energy
geological history plants have evolved
toward flowering plants and flowering
plants flowering plants appeared about
130 million years ago and became
dominant maybe around 65 million years
we are not sure whether it's before or
after dinosaur disappeared but around
that time so so that's when you know
tropical forest became dominantly
flowering plants so this case is if the
Amazon is covered by plants that don't
transpire much unlike the flowering
plants like you know ferns or other
types of plants when the rainy season or
the start so if present day on average
rainy season starts about late October
October 26 so that's you know just the
average but if we don't have plants
transpiring so during the transpiration
basically forest you know a provide
large amount of water to the atmosphere
so that you know that water can can
precipitate out and in that case we're
season starts in January 10th so it's
more than two months of the rainy season
difference and and you know take a look
at the duration it's about like 80 days
difference so plants are really
important in terms of determining
precipitation amount frequency and also
the duration of the rainy season and
this is the observed precipitation in
the Amazon so this is the difference
between this period and the earlier
period so later period minus earlier
period and what you see is that over the
northern part predation is increasing
and over the southern part presentation
is decreasing and so this is my study
and other people have shown that the
length of the west season and
particularly the onset of the rainy
season might have delayed during the
past years
and over at the same time what we see is
the changes in the greenness of the land
surface so this is the this is the data
from the satellites so we use the fact
that in a plants of plants observe a lot
of visible light because in a
chlorophyll of sorts blue blue and red
light but but bare ground you know but
they don't so plants absorb a lot of
visible light but not near-infrared but
bare ground they don't really there's
not much difference so by looking at how
visible light and infer near-infrared
light is observed by the land surface we
could see how much how much biomass we
have so that you know this satellite
observation and you can think of it as
you know how green the land surface so
I'm looking at that difference for the
same time so later period late I mean
from mid 92 early 2000s - 80s and early
90s and what you see is I'm only looking
at the September October November case
because during the wet season because
it's very wet we don't really see much
difference and the time that the land
surface is driest is the later dry
season or only wet season so what you
see is that this part of the region
becomes greener and this part of the
world becomes browner which you know it
is very similar to the precipitation
pattern so they're in a self-consistent
and I did some modeling study and trying
to figure out why we have this type of
precipitation change we call this an
attribution study so there are different
probably different factors that
influence precipitation over this region
and I have you know two possible
candidates for the possible change one
is
remote sea surface temperature forcing
so what we observe is that during the
past 30 years there's more warming in
regions over land because in I mean land
doesn't have high heat capacity more
warming over land more warming in the
polar region in the tropics we have more
warming in the regions around Indonesia
and we tend to have less warming in
eastern Pacific so this type of sea
surface temperature pattern has
influenced the precipitation and most of
the change most of the precipitation
change in the northern part is due to
the change in the remote forcing by sea
surface temperature and you thoughts
here is that where the difference is
statistically significant and then this
one is vegetation only the changes in
land views how that's going to influence
and particularly the southeastern part
predation changes seem to be coming from
the vegetation change and when we
combine them together
I mean it's smaller than the observation
but it captures the major pattern so I
just let you know that precipitation is
very difficult to simulate in a model
did I'd consider this like success so so
plants influence precipitation and and
how about like cloud types so I'm
looking at a satellite data that shows
the vertical distribution of cloud water
so you can think of it as you know radar
on the satellite so this is cloud types
over savanna
this is you know August September of
sorry August September October November
etc the blue part here is the wet season
this is height so this means that you
know in August we see mostly low
clouds at about four kilometer and in
December we start seeing clouds at about
10 kilometer so Klaus here is mostly
made of cloud liquid water and one cloud
here is mostly made of called out ice so
what we see is that during the wet
season clouds are taller with a lot of
ice and during the dry season less ice
and you know that's what so during the
during the wet season with very tall
clouds and during the dry season we see
a fairly shallow clouds over Savannah
and that's the kind of things that we'd
expected from even before looking at the
satellite data so this is I mean this is
a new satellite data and it's it was
it's you know really exciting time for
us so this is over the ocean and you see
that over the ocean there's a lot of
precipitation but most clouds are here
about six kilometers we call this
congestus so over the ocean I mean even
if there's more precipitation closer
shallower and most clouds are you know
around the freezing level so this is
mixture of cloud liquid and cloud ice
and over Amazon what we see is that most
of the time most of the time we see
fairly similar to similar parent to the
ocean so people call Amazon green ocean
and there was a TOI TOI funding called
green ocean Amazon that helped
collaboration between the scientists in
the US and in Brazil so so most of the
time there's a lot of moisture and it's
it's not too hot so conviction is fairly
low but but
during the transition season from dry to
wet what we see is this high clouds with
lots and lots of ice water and in that
case we feel you know very different
type of clouds and during the transition
season that's the end of the dry season
Sun is becoming stronger but still
there's a lot of moisture casino Amazon
is fairly wet we have deep soil water so
so temperature goes up maybe about a
degree and friends experience a little
bit of water stress so this is this is
an index for water stress and as you see
it goes up a little bit because of this
small increase in water stress
temperature goes up about a degree or
two and that provides enough buoyancy
for the atmosphere so now we can have
very strong conviction with lots and
lots of ice so and that's what we are
observing here and I'll just you know
wrap up here so transpiration is
important in determining the duration of
the rainy season frequency of the
rainfall and also determining the types
of clouds and land views probably
influence the precipitation pattern and
then further change in temperature and
land use in the future will probably
influence influence the hydrological
cycle over there lots of the intricacies
about climate change is not as simple as
you think so if anyone has questions for
Joan there were many technical aspects
that were very interesting I'm sure many
people are curious about water which is
yes
we're seeing things being discussed
about the tipping point and how much
land use change or deforestation you
know is will change basically the Amazon
forest to into a dry savanna and and
we've heard you know forty percent and
recently Carlos no beret and Tom Lovejoy
published an article talking about 25
percent deforestation will lead to this
tipping point and and clearly the kind
of research you're doing is very
relevant to perhaps understanding when
that tipping point is gonna happen do
you have any comment about that
so tipping point I mean that that's not
an easy answer but even with very small
deforestation what we see is that you
know cloud types are changing so if we
have you know deforested a spot that
tends to induce major scale circulation
and we tend to have shallow clouds
during the dry season so that type of
change we see even with a fairly small
amount of deforestation tipping point
there are two aspects one I mean the you
probably heard about this in our Peter
Cox study on Amazon die back and in from
death study the tie-back started even
without any deforestation so if we pump
up lots and lots of co2 and with lots of
co2 that changes the sea surface
temperature type in the Pacific and that
may induce Amazon die back so that you
know one possibility in terms of how in
a land surface input influence the
critical point so I don't have the
number and I'm not sure how well we can
actually do that but what I can say is
that as you saw from my work the time
that the precipitation is most dependent
on evapotranspiration is only
on set so what is important is the
plants you know and the soil keep water
until the end of the dry season if and
and that's very important for
agriculture etc but if we in a converted
area into agricultural land that region
might not have enough water until the
end of the dry season so yeah so in that
sense you know every conversion into
agriculture would be really bad for you
know moisture recycling but exactly how
much I don't have a very good number
do you have numbers about the secondary
forests you mean like in my marrow
yeah the forest that's formed after the
forest station so in so secondary
forests you know they have different
root structure and sometimes no slightly
different characteristics that kind of
change that kind of difference is not
yet into this model so as I said you
know what is important is you know the
routing depth and so on and it seems to
me that you know early succession I may
not be actually correct about early
succession seems to have less deeper
deep roots but maybe other people who
know much more about plants can have
right the way water deficit will affect
different types of vegetation is not the
same seedlings E&C mature trees young
secondary force made secondary force
etcetera okay we have to end here and
thank you so much
have our next speaker Susan thank you
all for the opportunity to enter this
interesting discussion about Brazilian
studies I'm a socio-cultural
anthropologist so I've taken this from a
completely different direction so it
it's a little bit more of a historical
look at research in Brazil
anthropological research in Brazil has
contributed to the conceptualization and
protection of biomes in that it's called
into question and complicated the
boundaries between nature and humanity a
wide variety of research in Brazil has
caused us to question a question if we
should be thinking about biomes as
exclusively natural and that goes back
30 or 40 years as been mentioned in the
seventies natural spaces were places
where humans were not supposed to be and
I really think it is research in Brazil
that has changed our thinking on that
quite a bit so it's made a big impact
archeology research with contemporary
people's based in historical ecology the
social anthropology of Eduardo Viveiros
de Castro at the Museo Nacional called
perspectivism as well as critiques of
perspectivism which also come from
Brazil as well as elsewhere has all
complicated our understanding of nature
versus the human these bodies of
research and the dialogue they have
engendered with respect to these
categories point to the many ways that
indigenous Amazonians are integral to
the protection of Brazilian biomes so I
just want to review the contributions of
these different approaches with this
goal in mind
archeology archaeological research in
Brazil has been key for showing how the
human and the natural are entangled
rather than being categorized simply as
either wild or wrecked forests and serra
dos are coming to be seen as rooted in
and contingent on human actions and
social configurations of the past to
quote Susannah Hecht and her co-authors
this complex relationship between humans
and nature is seen with respect to the
composition of soils River flora and
fauna beginning 4000 years ago Amazonian
started to manage forests in many places
Brazil nut tree stands were encouraged
and single species forests of açaí palm
created at one site adjacent to the
juncture of the Negro and the solely
moist rivers Eduardo nevus and James
Peterson have shown that over the course
of long-term occupation during the first
millennium ad vast amounts of fertile
Amazonian dark earth were formed from
the acidic yellow soil by humans mound
building and cultivation methods created
a forest mosaic of secondary growth
surrounded by larger areas of high
forest the upper Xingu central brazil is
another key location for showing the
long-term development of landscapes by
indigenous peoples long scene is
pristine and protected by a reserve
since the mid 20th century areas around
the headwaters of the Xingu River are
covered with sites where there were once
nodes of high population houses built
around central plazas each node
connected by roads to form lattice like
structures according to Michael Hagen
Berger this formation reached its height
between 1250 and 1400 AD and the land
between these nodes was carefully
managed with Weir's ponds causeways
fields of sap a grass for thatch and
picky nut tree groves research with
contemporary Amazonians shows that
forage management and knowledge
continues in central brazil the Chi
opposed practice of low-level burning
favours in Asia and to kuma palms it's
also linked to the formation of dark
earth while William ballet has found the
Kapoor of eastern Brazil create a new
kind of old-growth forest which enhances
species diversity again upper Xingu
lands who have used fire as a tool for
landscape management and have monitored
rainfall for their agricultural cycles
for thousands of years have a wealth of
knowledge passed between generation
about current changes in rainfall and
conditions now leading to uncontrollable
fires this sort of knowledge is useful
both for sustainable management and the
documentation of changes in biomes it is
also a resource that Garner's
international support in income the
Kapoor for example initiated a project
in 2000 2009
funded by the World Wildlife Foundation
and Rios Museo to India to support the
transmission of forest knowledge this
program has been influential in fighting
logging in the Xingu the associates
al-hajjaj isa manchester Xingu with the
help of the instituto socio ambient al
has been enlisting Xingu instance since
2007 to gather native seeds to sell to
reforest deforested areas outside of the
Xingu the Xingu park anyway the other
body of work that is probably ties the
boundaries between nature and humanities
is that a Fed wardo Viveiros de Castro
and his students based on his own field
research and with the central Brazilian
auto 8a his mastery of other lowland
ethnographies which is immense as well
as his dialogue with the philosophy of
de Luz and live East roses structuralism
he has put forth a general
characterization of Amazonian thought
which has been extremely influential in
anthropology and beyond according to
this formulation in contrast to Western
thought Amerindian thought is guided by
multi naturalism a mode that apprehends
humans and animals equally as persons as
united by their common humanity but
understands them to have different
perspectives because they possess
different types of bodies in contrast
multiculturalism and naturalism
characterized the West this mode of
thought is founded on seeing a shared
biological nature between all living
things but a division between nature and
culture culture being the force
that separates humans from animals and
gives rise to human difference the human
is the domain of agency and creativity
and is set above the more passive nature
with the aim of decolonizing thought
multi naturalism and naturalism are not
simply taken as characteristic of
different cultural perspectives on a
shared world but rather as an entirely
different as different realities or
ontology x' with respect to the group i
know best the Calumet a a people who
have relocated to the Xingu Park from
more heavily colonized areas to the west
in the Tapajos River area multi at
naturalism could be said to characterize
the domains of myth and shamanism in the
deep forest under water and at the
horizon live vestiges of beings that
populated the earth in mythic times
before humans and animals die variegated
these ancient and powerful beings called
the true animals control and watch over
everyday animals of the forest who are
considered to be their pets or their
children the true animals take human
souls in revenge for the animals killed
in the hunt the souls of the sick the
dead and the unborn are kept as their
packs or children until Shaymin can
negotiate their return to the human
world aspects of what we would call part
of the natural environment are always in
route to becoming transformed into the
human and vice-versa and rather than
simply calories animals are also non
human subjectivity z' surprisingly the
cow a wit a are not as a result
vegetarians rather hunting and predation
are central but moral codes in the form
of dietary taboos and rules about the
treatment of game as well as shamanic
interventions guide their engagement
with these beings to quote Viveiros de
Castro this sort of ontology causes the
human condition to cease being special
and to become instead a default mode or
a generic condition of any species the
domain of nature also in essence
disappears
the traditions of many other lowland
people can be described in similar terms
as presenting a transformational world
populated with many kinds of human and
non-human persons anthropologists such
as al sita rama said Oh an eBay and and
others based based on their respective
fieldwork have observed that
perspectivism leads to a dangerous
homogenous ation a portrayal of very
distinctive indigenous traditions in
generic terms terms that are basically
an essential eyes
alter image of the West perspectivism
has also in fire inspired field research
in Siberia native North America
Melanesia as well as beyond where
similar kinds of thought have been
identified this body of work could
really in fact be said to essentialize a
global indigenous thought that is
counter posed to that of the West so as
you can see it is a little bit it is not
structuralism but it's inspired by some
of the Universalist
claims of structuralism although for
Eduardo he splits them into Western and
non-western but and you can see there
could be reasons to to mind that native
Amazonian or non-western perspectivism
as such has however become a position
which some of the positions of
capitalist development can be addressed
perhaps because of its elegance in its
formulation or its grounding in myth
rather than the complexities of history
because it's not very historical
prospective ism offers a vision of a
different kind of world that is possible
in the future beyond that of our current
world system as such it has the
potential to galvanize support in
industrialized nations for indigenous
people and their environments Shaymin
working through translators like
Brazilian Davi Copenhagen Oh mommy have
become really compelling spokespersons
far beyond Amazonia for this other way
to live multi naturalism also has
currency among indigenous activists and
Indian countries as a means of uniting
people of different traditions in
opposition to
development projects with respect to its
usefulness in political rhetoric it's
pret-a-porter nature to quote Ramos is
perhaps actually an asset as is futurist
orientation with respect to protecting
biomes it's a vision of both an
indigenous world and ideal future where
there is no category of the human
differentiated from nature and therefore
no human domination of nature the
problem with this as Lucas Besser and
David bond have pointed out is that this
multi naturalist world entirely cut off
from the West does not exist save
perhaps in myth or this vague future it
leads to an artificial and dangerous
perception of Amazonians living in
separate realities when in fact they're
entangled in the material problems we
all share the effects of fossil fuels
tailings from mines DDT mercury etc
perspectivism they caution may also lead
to a discounting and Anan recognition of
indigenous people who are not fully cut
off from Western reality and this is
just about the everyone the vast
majority of them they suggest instead
looking at you know to look at people's
actual working relations with the
natural world and with respect to the
commie wit a I've written about a
shaman's involvement in the march to the
west or a march of our West G in
mid-century this particular Shaymin in
preppy worked with the Brazilian Air
Force ground truthing across central
brazil to establish landing strips in
the 40s at the same time as he
communicated with the true animals so
that these team key teams could have
game to eat and that their airplanes
would not be taken down by heavy winds
he did this he said to bring the comet a
better medical treatment that the air
travel allowed he also worked with these
spirits and with the indigenous amother
villas-boas brothers to help set up the
Xingu indigenous park finding how
indigenous alterity is entangled and
enmeshed with goals and goals and
projects shared across ethnic boundaries
provides more realistic template
for how conservation or development
project projects
sustainable or otherwise involving
indigenous peoples have worked or not
worked to protect biomes one current
interesting project sponsored sponsored
by the instituto socio ambient isle is
the production of organic honey in the
Xingu made from both the Africanized
bees honey's as well as the stingless
Amazonian bee bees honeys
honey honey as those are plural this
honey is produced in the Xingu and sold
to a grocery store chain the pound jassu
occur for profit while kaya bee had
experienced with native stingless bees
and gathering their honey the art of
beekeeping was new very much a Western
craft
according to simonia Hachiya a axiality
and her co-authors this venture has also
led to the documentation of the
interaction of native and European bees
and the monitoring of forest blooms in
the Xingu it has led including to a
discovery of by kya B Shaymin of a new
spirit that controls and watches over
the European bees in conclusion while
archaeology cultural ecology
perspectivism and its critics can all
contribute to conceptualizing biomes and
work towards their protection they do it
in different ways or have done it in
different ways archaeology and cultural
ecology produce a fine grain
understanding of humans roles in
particular contexts and their historical
trajectories perspectivism a bit
actually like the archaeology of the 70s
which theorized about populations across
the whole amazon basin deals in broad
generalities that are a historical but
they have it has a clear rhetorical
appeal and it can be used as a platform
for activism against destructive
development projects critiques of
perspectivism document the way
environmental protection or degradation
can happen in a more historically
specific way across inter-ethnic divides
and conceptual worlds these approaches
provide a realistic idea about
how these joint ventures can work or
maybe don't work
so in short Brazil and research in
Brazil has been really important for
Rican ception iliza the biome we have a
few minutes for questions for Suzanne
and then we'll open it to a general yes
definition so could you define it a
definition that was that big bond
paragraph in there did you find it
though as you googled it did it come up
as a word no its Eduardo it's coined by
this anthropologist ed Eduardo that part
of anneristo Castro at the Museo
Nacional and what he means by that is
this Ana's first he started saying it's
just sort of an equal used
Amerindians the term he used an
Amerindian thought versus a Western
thought and the way he defines it is
that we in the West have nature versus
culture and and these amerindians don't
have that split instead they view all
creatures as equally cultural but having
it but they have different bodies and
therefore view the world differently so
whereas humans
whereas Westerners talk about culture as
the thing that differentiates humans and
nature
Amerindians don't have that term and
they think more in terms of
perspectivism and that would be the
definition it is it is very much like
levy Strozzi and structuralism of the
past in the sense that it is it's a very
jinn it's a very it's very elegant and
very kind of generic at the same time
and it's also based he knows just an
amazing amount about all the literature
that has come out of the lowlands so
it's not something that he just started
with from you know an ultra image of the
web
but that's what he ended up with so it's
sort of hunting force these universe
it's not a universal because it's the
west of the non West but it hunts for
this and very rich ethnographic terrain
so it's kind of paradoxical in the way
levy Strauss was he came up with these
like really kind of banal universals
about the human mind but he did it by
going through all this detailed
ethnography so you could never say oh
it's just an alter image of the West
it's ridiculous it's based on a lot of
empirical data from it so it's it's a
curious it's and it's taken the world by
storm I mean really if you want to talk
about a Brazilian impacting something
made anthropology in the last 20 years
This Is It this is what Brazilian
anthropology is bringing to really the
world it is caught on like wildfire in
Europe u.s. is a bit you know mixed on
it but definitely is interested it's
it's huge so I'm kind of surprised it
didn't come up but I'm not sure what
they would have written google is not
the end of the world just a brief
question and we'll start with our
general discussion yeah whenever if
question okay now I was just very
curious about that topic of
perspectivism is Vijay Castro and the
critique because one of the critics that
you mentioned is that it disconnects the
indigenous peoples of the Amazon from
the West let's say but when we read that
the köppen our he is able to go back and
forth and he's very cosmopolitan and
that kind of Kozma so so it doesn't have
to be and at the same time he coincides
with the Viveiros de Castro I mean he
describes it very elegantly to so I
guess my question would be like what
kind of this kind of new intellectual
indigenous intellectual how rather than
just the anthropologists can
how can we collaborate with them and you
as anthropologists so it's not a
surprise that it looks very much like
wow here it is again
I think perspectivism given my like long
answer to what is it I think it's really
tricky to try to necessarily work with
indigenous intellectuals I think it's
really tricky to to try to explain all
that with at least say intellectuals in
the Xingu I know I have tried it and
it's not always super easy but you can
you can see in the Indian countries it's
something that has been picked up by say
urban indigenous intellectuals and
they've really have run with it because
it is really rhetorically useful and
interesting and it galvanizes people so
I'm not I don't quite know the answer I
guess it's a complicated answer - I
don't even know it alright good good way
to our respective locations we open now
to general discussions so please all
these questions that you've been saving
from from Joan now from Suzanne now you
can open your mind son shoot we are
ready to answer questions for you you
can ask you can ask questions to me too
why not and we have microphones yep
circulating they're two different people
holding microphones for you okay got the
mic now he's the first up there
you'd be second we have a total of eight
to ten minutes for for general
discussion yeah so please say keep your
question short and I will ask the
panelists to keep your answers if
possible all of all research that I know
of in Amazonia but especially things
having to do with indigenous people or
with with environmental projects are
deeply politicized at the local level at
the national level at the international
level so I guess my question is not only
to the panel but to others in the
audience is what let's not talk about
tipping points but what political
conditions could make this kind of
multinational collaboration this kind of
research work which requires
institutional local negotiation of
permissions what could make it better
and easier okay who offered the panel
would like to answer first otherwise
we'll leave it up to somebody in the
audience who may answer anyone like
Bette or June or Susanne it has an
answer what kind of political setting
that's a really great question and
something that we all struggle with
because sometimes that the local
government actors are not very open you
know to the particular kind of research
or alliances of organizations and
researchers that may be operating in a
particular area I mean I think that from
from our perspective is that I can't go
in the University of Florida can't go in
and expect to establish those kinds of
relationships that we really do rely on
our partners on the ground to be able to
sort of open the doors and to build the
the agreements and formal agreements
that you know can outline specifically
you know what we're hoping to accomplish
together and so forth on the other hand
we have also found that an organization
like the University of Florida and
somebody from the outside can sometimes
be a neutral partner and can bring
together you know organizations that may
and be in conflict with each other that
may not come to the table together if
one or the other or maybe the government
was was organizing you know a particular
forum or discussion whereas they might
be more willing to come to the table and
talk about their interest with sort of a
neutral partner I'm not sure that's
really adjust your questions but just so
be something that's it yeah an absurd
evasion yes please so I have an
experience in working with my Brazilian
colleague and you know what helped us
most is the funding from there wasn't
enough Brazilian side so there was this
I mentioned during my talk that there
was this in a green ocean Amazon call
from the Department of Energy of the US
and for from that court they asked us to
came up with with Brazilian colleague
and in theory you know supported us and
sample of Research Foundation support my
Brazilian colleague and that was the
most useful thing for us to in have all
this in a research activity happened so
the research funding I mean because I
mean everyone is busy it's just you know
without funding it's very difficult to
like establish collaboration and my
colleague told me that you know the
funding is a bit drying up in Brazil and
that's the case for the US as well so
particularly for the you know for the
tropical research I mean I was asked
that in a lot of research really
that it's related to topics we are
encouraged to study per Toriko
instead of Brazil so things like that
you know that's the difficulty mm-hmm I
think we can go on to the next question
please
a little bit different I'd like to
transfer here at the to congratulate
today's speaker how do you think that
the Forex transition that comes together
if a demographic transition afterwards
can contribute for the emergence of
infectious disease or chronic disease
that's a very interesting question so
you mean that how the the changes in
force to influence disease human disease
so that's not you know the area that I'm
very familiar with but we had stood
student at Brown who study the link
between disease and deforestation and
what they were finding is that the the
regions where disease outbreaks
particularly like you know coming from
animals basically is where deforestation
occurs so not you know urban area or not
in the middle of the forest but the
forested area so that study region was
actually not in Brazil but India so with
more deforestation there's more
interaction and you know that's where
the disease outbreaks you know the
number is we had the long term project
between the School of Forestry no
movement the studies and the School of
Public Health Department of Public
Health of School of Medicine and back in
the nineties funded by the Rockefeller
Foundation and Canadian needed for
International Development and we were
focusing on our Bo viruses so arthropod
borne diseases viruses transmitted by
arthropods and
we were focusing on yellow fever malaria
of course and leptospirosis left by
roses and we studied how that happens
the those diseases are in the forest and
there are animals birds and small
mammals who host the insects that then
may host the viruses and the cycle of
the disease is there but then when
humans come into the forest to cut the
forest to collect rubber or to harvest
Brazil nuts the cycle must be broken may
be broken and then some of those insects
may bite a human and from their own the
human brings it back to his his or her
human habitation so then it becomes a
peri-urban type of disease is no longer
a forest this is a very old man disease
so then how to break that because that's
what you don't want some of those
diseases are not fatal but they produce
lots of economic loss and all kinds of
psychological issues on people of course
some of them are fatal like different
types of malaria can be depending on
what type of population to children or
and and all that but definitely changes
in land use are very very influential
and we came up with recommendations in
terms of changes of land use that
shouldn't be made on how to how to go
through the forest and cut and not to be
exposed all kinds of and and there are
still some people at the School of
Public Health that could answer your
questions with more detail because I was
from the point of view of the land use
changes on the forestry and then they
are people were the ones who did all
they came all the chemical and medical
studies yeah I think we have time for
one more question unless Asia may want
to say something about time our time is
supposed to run until 4:30 and we're now
433 so can we get one more question Asia
tells me we have time for one more
question
great that's wonderful thank you very
much you all very good presentations and
my question relates to carbon credits
you must be familiar I don't know but
it's it's been sold in Brazil many
there's many European companies and it
came to my attention one specific case I
have my brother is a human rights lawyer
in Brazil defending a case of an
indigenous group against a European
company that bought carbon credits for
several decades and now they're
forbidden even to practice their own
like they can't fish they can't hunt
they can they can build their own style
of houses housing because they are not
allowed to DeForest and it's considered
the traditional lifestyle is considered
deforestation so I just want to ask if
you're familiar with it if there is any
may be I think that you know that I can
provide a dialogue between the because
what I think it's lack of dialogue is
essential there in several fields that
involved in this area I don't know since
the Suzanne has an answer for you yes I
actually I don't really have an answer
but which group was that you Souter we
yeah I mean obviously it's I don't have
an answer I think it's a really tricky
topic and there have been a lot of
people writing about the carbon credits
with indigenous groups I wish I were
more on top of that literature I don't
know but it's not obviously a panacea
yeah definitely because the indigenous
peoples there have been lots of studies
done in Panama where the the Kuna Yala
the Kuna people meaning the people from
that's their name Kuna meaning people
Kuna Yala and they
when all these ideas about the red
project started and Panama was chosen
because of the general good conditions
of the country good communications good
Maps and etc Panama was chosen almost as
as a model country to implement red
projects reducing emissions for the from
the forestation and degradation and then
the Kuna Yala were asked to come into
the dialogue good that they did that and
I was there at the time and the
Smithsonian Institution was in charge of
much of that conversation and they
claimed that the carbon is theirs
because they have been in their land for
a long time and as you may know half of
the carbon stock in the world is in that
in the soil and not in the forest we
tend to think about the trees and
because they are there they are more
easy to see but the soils are more
difficult to study but in reality if you
look at what the IPCC an international
Panel on Climate Change and cetera says
half of the carbon world widest is in
the soil and they claimed the Kuna Yala
claimed that the soil is theirs but of
course it depends on the countries of
the world what lies under your soil is
yours or not like in this country if you
find oil is yours
in our countries to find yours is we
find oil it belongs to the country like
Ecuador and things like that so but the
Kuna Yala claim the soil was theirs and
that was their carbon so it had to be
compensated for that and then I won't
tell you the end of the story because I
didn't continue on those and that kind
of a discussion a little bit died kind
of like out of exhaustion there were no
simple answers as Suzanne's I'm just
telling you that there is a very strong
case I think from the point of view of
the indigenous people they have been on
their land for millennia and they own
the soil there is no discussion why
would the government of Panama or an arc
and
say that the soil resources are theirs I
do not know that is unethical and I
think discussion there but there is a
very strong argument for in favor of the
local people that that's their carbon so
in terms of assigning carbon credits
that's becomes very fascinating so with
that said I think we need to close the
word panel and we thank you all of you
for your attention and I think we're
going to have something outside or we
can continue no we can continue HSS no
an Asia has the lead here so but of
course there may be inform informal
talking if people want to stay around
with the panelists or among yourselves
and we'll see you tomorrow
a welcome you please say you do the
announcements yeah there's another
session in just a few minutes okay just
a few minutes you'll be back here for
the next step and thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]